markers and specifically what i'll be
talking about today is automating you
know the tools of order flows with
markers to help you
take trades basically you know
a lot of people have this problem of
taking trades you know they spend a lot
of money on
software on
you know hardware computers and all that
and then sometimes it comes down to
actually taking the trades
they hesitate you know and there's the
saying you know he who hesitates is lost
and you know sometimes the difference of
getting into a trade late
and getting into a trade as quick as you
can
you know can make the difference of
whether you're going to be profitable or
not i mean it sounds
simple in theory you know hey i'm a
trader i'm going to trade but you know
sometimes people have issues pulling the
trigger now i know a lot of people think
of you know when they think automate
trading
they want a system that's just going to
do everything for them and
i want to
talk about some of the pros and cons of
that today so
let me get started
excuse me here uh make sure my screen is
up you know before we begin you know
do understand i mean you all adults
right we all understand that trading
involves risk and
you know only risk capital should be
used for trading only those with
sufficient risk apple should consider
trading you know as silly as it sounds i
i do get people emailing me saying you
know what mike i got laid off of my job
and i'm on unemployment for the next
three months and i need to learn how to
trade in those three months so i don't
have to go back
a to a job well those are not the prime
conditions to learn how to trade can it
be done yes i mean there are people that
have literally picked up trading but
they have a specific background okay
they they're adept to it so and we all
come from different backgrounds in life
you know for myself you know i'm i grew
up in the chicago area and you know i
was exposed to the cme the cbot since
basically i've been a teenager and so
it's a natural progression for me um you
know pablo is from south america and he
has a different background
than myself and you know he's come in
and he sort of he's found his area
within trading so even though everybody
has different backgrounds
you have to find the area in trading
that you're good at and
build on it so let's talk about
automated trading you know is it for you
you know what are the pros and cons and
i'm going to show you how to automate
with markers and i'm going to show you
how i use it because you know when
people think of automated traded they
just think their computer is going to
just start spitting out cash
you know they're just going to load a
computer they're going to buy
you know some software for how many
thousands of dollars turn it on and go
to bed
wake up in the morning
look at their account and see it growing
every every time they look at it
unfortunately it doesn't work that way
right that's not reality we all wish it
was and you know when i started this
presentation i talked about trading
involves risk
and you have to understand that then
even with automated trading there are
risks involved you know there have been
times even
you know professional trading companies
you know the goldman sachs you know
they've had errors
quite big errors where algos just also
turned on in the middle of the night
that executed big baskets of futures
orders right and it's cost them tens of
millions of dollars so even though
things are automated in theory
you know it sounds great but
it's not perfect in that sense okay now
there's two different ways to use
automated trading there's fully
automated which is you know trade entry
and trade exit
and this is what i call partially
automated which is the trade entry is
automated and you manage the trade
and the exit okay now
if a trade is going your way that's fine
you could let it sit there but you know
as
as a trader you really want to trade the
market because sometimes you're going to
see things happening
in the market that go contrary to you
getting into the trade and the way
i describe you know why you should
automate it is because you know
you got the good devil on one side the
bad devil on the other side um you know
should i take this trade or not you know
you're sitting there you have your
indicator and you know even though
people have indicators they don't always
take the signals you know sometimes that
people will be like well
you know this i have this fancy
indicator
and it just had two losses in a row
should i take the next one or not well
you should because you got to stick to
your method of trading you know you
can't all of a sudden start
trading your trading method if you do
that you're going to end up
missing out the trades that you should
have taken and you end up oftentimes you
know as murphy's law would have it
taking the trades
that you should that you shouldn't okay
so
when i talk about partially
automated what i mean is i'm a hands-on
i like to read the order flow
you know everybody that's familiar with
me that's from um that's joined today
from my list
know that i'm an order flow guy okay and
i've been teaching order flow
to the retail public since
what was that 2015 you know so we're
coming on on seven years already and
it's important you know to be a trader
when it comes to trading now there's
nothing wrong with
automating something but you know
oftentimes when when you fully automate
something 100
automation
there's going to be drawdowns okay and
sometimes people can't
stomach a drawdown
right it's one thing to
wake up
go to bed turn on your system and it's
working fine
you wake up you got a nice tidy profit
but it's another thing to wake up see
something happened right maybe you had a
position on or something and this is you
know power went out or something and you
know things got screwed up and also now
you're sitting on a loss so you know
just bear that in mind those are some of
the cons of
um
fully automated so for me i like to go
partially automated i like to use
the software to get me into the trade so
you know i'm not sitting there thinking
uh you know i remove
that piece of
psychological baggage
thinking should i take this trade or not
you know sometimes we're looking at um
you know an email or you get a text
message and we turn our head away from
the screen for you know a second and
then you know there's a trade you should
take by the time you take it you've
you've missed your entry okay but having
an automated
trade entry is going to help you
ultimately become
a better trader by getting into the
trade
by removing that part of the actual
trade entry away from you so
once you're in the trade
let me ask you right would you rather
get stopped out at your full amount or
stopped out or at halfway right or would
you just be happy to scratch the trade
because you know sort of the the thing
that people that like to automate
everything
is
they
expect all their trades to go to profit
right go to their their profit level
or go stop out right and you know this
was today in the in the mes right there
was this nice run up to uh 12
this was this morning about 9 30 just
after 9 30 12 and three quarters right
got this nice move up
and you know if you're getting long
looking for
you know five points
getting along somewhere here is you know
breaking out of the new highs you know
coming out of 0809 you know with the
level around 14 or 15 it didn't get
there right it didn't go all the way up
to your take profit level we wish it
would but sometimes just just what the
market does right just it just puts in a
move and then it just goes sideways and
then it falls over right then it gives
you a short signal okay now oftentimes
the problem that i see with with some
traders is they get the signal they get
in
and it just sort of goes sideways
and they're just sitting here waiting
for it to go up to their take profit
level
they're not recognizing what's happening
in the order flow
or you know in the price action
and
then they get a sell signal
but they're still married to this
original trade thinking well no i'm
waiting for it to go to my my take
profit level
right then what happens you get the sell
signal then the market falls over so
rather than scratching the trade or
taking you know a tiny profit or a small
loss
then when the next signal this time a
bearish signal comes in
take advantage of it and this second
signal is the one that went to the take
profit so the first signal didn't go to
the take profit but the second signal
did and you know that's why i i talk
about when you know managing the trades
is is just as important as
having a reason to get into a trade okay
now
you know we've all had those times where
we've had winning trades turn into
losers right i love that meme from
um but i can't think of the show right
now but
um
you know joe exotic i'm never going to
financially recover from this where you
have the nice winning trade right it's
just going in your favor right just like
this morning in the e-minis it's going
in your favor then it just goes sideways
and then you get stopped out right and
it's like ah that's the worst time but
that's where reading order flow is going
to help you all right but i'll get into
that a bit later
now
oftentimes right if you know how to read
the market right and again i'm an order
flow guy i spend a lot of time teaching
people how to read the order flow
there's signs when the market is not
going your way right if you're in a
trade
and you're not getting
things follow following through in the
order flow right if you're getting short
off this bar right i got the this is the
um pulse giving me a cell signal right
here and then i just see it goes
sideways right i'm short but then i see
positive delta creep in i don't see big
negative delta i see point of controls
going higher i see um
buying imbalances well that's not what i
want to see when i'm in a trade so this
i'm getting short up here at 01 looking
for a move down into
you know below 95
instead it's just creeping higher point
of control is going higher buying
imbalances deltas are not negative
they're small positive but more
importantly they're not negative right i
want to see the aggressive selling
coming in and eventually they would have
gone up here and stopped me out up here
at o5 okay
so
you know
understand learn how to read the road
signs because why should you get stopped
out up here at 05 when you could just
see it going along here you're short at
you know at 01 but it's trading 02 and
it's just
not giving you anything right you're not
getting paid you're short but instead
you're seeing buying coming in
aggressive buying coming in
value you know the point controls are
moving higher so value is moving higher
and the bars price is moving higher you
know it that's where
when i talk about being
partially automated as opposed to fully
automated you're fully automated you're
fully stopped out
partially you know it's better to take a
one-point loss than you know a
four-point loss
because you know at the end of the day
markets eventually turn all right again
this is mes this morning market was
going up nice move up okay
well moves don't go to infinity
right i mean we wish they were you know
back in when i was on the on the cme
floor
and i
this is gosh back in the 90s
is somebody i used to
trade a opening range breakout right and
i would often hold it until the close um
unless you know there was a reversal
signal intraday and i remember somebody
asked me
why do you
get out on the close you know where's
your don't you have a legitimate take
profit or anything uh my
ex
excuse was i expected trade to go to
infinity but trades don't go to infinity
right markets eventually turn and at
those turning points if you're not
picking it up right if you're not
realizing that the market is turning
you're going to miss out on the move
back down
so can
order flow
be
automated it can right but you need to
be dialed in on your charge selection
you need to be dialed in on your stock
level and take profit so in order to
automate order flow you need to identify
trade setups right because ultimately
what you're doing is you're telling the
computer software
the reason to buy the reason to sell
it's not that you just have a footprint
up on your chart
and expect the computer to take buys and
sells for you well
not unless you tell
for example right you have to be
explicit to the computer right because
computers just follow instructions okay
for example right you got to give it a
certain parameters you know delta
increasing by a certain percentage over
an x number of bars you need to give it
something that it can analyze and at
order flows you know we've created many
different orderful based indicators
right the delta scalper the pulse the
turns
uh market exhaustion flow scalper flow
shifts low edges most recently flow
breaks
now again this is not an exhaustive list
and you don't have to use all of them
right there's
different things in the order flow
that
you can use okay because you know with
order flow there's delta there's point
of control
there's imbalances you know you have max
delta you have min delta
um
you've got really it's very robust
there's a lot of different aspects of
order flow so for example okay
this is wheat right this is with our new
flow brakes indicator
so there was an entry this was on friday
or thursday rather um
7 51 and a quarter okay now i use
a uh what is that a two and a half point
take profit a two point stop okay market
went all the way up touched my take
profit level
okay but i didn't get filled right and
then what happened
it eventually went down right eventually
went to the stop now
this is where
managing the trade comes in right
because if you're not managing or if you
go fully automated
you're gonna get stopped out right
you're gonna take the full two cent stop
loss but if you're
managing the trade
it comes up to your take profit level
happy all right but you don't get filled
right because it's a cube based system
and then you start seeing it drift down
right you start seeing the negative
deltas come in right at this point you
know you're long at one and a quarter
and you have all this time around 752
you know you came up to your take profit
and it's come off couldn't you know
traded there a few times in two bars
then it starts drifting down lower point
of controls you're seeing selling
imbalances come in
and again you're seeing the negative
delta right you're long so what do you
want to see right you want to see
positive delta right you did get one bar
here with nice positive delta of 76 but
other than that nothing special you know
one bar here was 63 but then again
a positive delta of 63 but then again x
bar negative delta of 57
bar after that negative delta of 27.
you're still in the money you're still
above your entry at 751 and a quarter
here
but right now all the signs are
concluding that the market's going lower
and eventually it did and it went down
to the stop price
again here's another long that failed
right long at 750 market going up up up
and then it just peaked right here and
dropped right well if you're watching
the delta again you're long so what are
you expecting to happen in the market
you're expecting
positive deltas you're not getting any
positive you've got one bar here with a
three positive delta but then you get
negative delta
minus 48 minus 40.
you're seeing lower point of control
right you got a this is a
bearish point of control up here you're
seeing exhaustion prints right so
everything is is turning bearish now at
this point you're only
in this bar right here at 749
you know 749 749 and a half you have an
area to get out at maybe one cent loss
maybe half a cent
rather than letting it come to your full
stop out
now this one is interesting um this is
again this is a short this time okay
so short at 7 48 and a half it just sort
of goes sideways okay then the selling
starts coming in you got your limit down
here 746 it gets within
you know one tick here it gets within
one tick it's turning 70 46 and a
quarter comes up a little bit
doesn't quite get to your stop but signs
are negative right you got the negative
deltas you got the lower points of
control you got those selling and
balances but it doesn't fill you okay
then
it comes down finally hit your take
profit
doesn't fill you right only two watch
trade there again it's a q system so
you're at the end of the queue
oftentimes unfortunately but um
market starts going back up okay so
again it came within a tick when
sideways hit it to the tick didn't fill
you unfortunately starts trading back up
breaks up trades back up to unchanged
again if you're watching the trade
unfold
while it hit your take profit you know
you're hoping that you could have got
filled it didn't happen that's the
reality of trading um you know you have
limits in the
order book sometimes you don't get
filled right sometimes there's
doesn't trade enough or there's just too
much in front of you or a combination of
both now it's trading back up to
you know your entry price it's a little
bit in the money
you got to make that decision you know
what are you going to do you got to
get out or you know in this case you get
out here you know maybe half a cent you
know or a quarter cent right now
or scratch it and just wait for the next
trade um you know there's no
shame in taking a small profit now
people say well you know
that's not a good way to trade well fine
what would you rather do get fully
stopped out at 750 which eventually this
trade did stop get stopped out at 750
and a half
or
book a small profit right that's how
reading order flow is going to help you
as a trader
now
lastly before i turn it over to pablo
this is another trade okay
short here
the market was coming off right i was
short from above took a
take profit here with another short
signal came in so short in here this is
about 11 55
and it's just going sideways
11 55 next thing you know it's 12 30
already okay and it's just spinning your
wheels
right
nothing
telling me to get short i'm short and
what do i see positive delta positive
delta positive delta positive delta
positive delta positive delta positive
delta for a half hour of being in the
trade you know that's
a negative sign
for your position right if you're short
and instead you're seeing
positive deltas that that's not a good
sign of the market going to go in your
favor and has been doing that for a half
hour and eventually this market did come
up back up to 750 and a half but you had
a chance to get out here
even at break even
at a
quarter or a half a cent loss even up
here at a full cent loss rather than
taking the full loss so
i'm going to turn it over to pablo and
then
you know i want you guys i'm going to
talk about take you through um
a session i'm going to show you on on
replay because it's already 4 20 but um
on friday thursday or friday i'm not
sure which day i got up there in the
wheat with
one of the
our indicators to read the order flow so
let me uh turn it over to pablo here
real quick give me a second here
okay
give me a sec
hello everyone okay let me uh see if i
turn this over here to you
i could hear you okay um make presenter
okay
you should have be able to get the
screen now
okay
okay i could see your screen
which one
i see looks like the amazon
okay this is the one
yeah
that one okay mes
okay then we are ready
hello everyone
i'm really happy to be here and
my my i i want to thank to
mike for the invitation um
for those who
know me
i
i have a lot of questions uh i i guess
um
for those who are asking how to do this
and that or how to automate
certain indicator with some kind of
filter um
i have so many questions that i prefer
to answer
in the chat room okay
for those who don't know the chatroom i
i will i i will explain later
how to hope you can access the chatroom
the chatroom is free you can get a
support
on how using markers how to create your
rules how to automate so
let's go to um
signals okay because here we have
signals from one of them
one of mike's indicator
and one of the most common question is
first of all how to automate the signals
and second how can i do something else
like for example add a filter okay this
one is the flow shift
but
now you will see that the answer to
how to automate the signal is very
simple and
most of the damage is
in the same process okay
so
first of all
the triangles those triangles
are from a mike's indicator
and this this is something also
important because if you have an
indicator
okay
where you know and this is indicator
and you know
that the signals are
plots
this is one of the sections on the
parameters of your indicator and this
applies to any indicator all indicators
if you have plots
then you know that it is compatible and
you can optimize on
with a markers
and even more you can optimize on
builder but this is part of a training
session that i am doing all weeks this
this is
you you need a ninja script coding for
that and i am doing a training session
for that but for markers for
markers you only need to know
the name of the plots and usually we
only have two plots one for longs
another for shorts
there are some indicators i guess
the
flow scalper
where no
not this one
maybe the flow shift
where we have two different okay
or this one the flow rex
no
okay never mind there are some
indicators that where you have more than
one plot
for example
a
strong lungs or weak longs strong shorts
with shorts something like that or a
long signal with a certain condition or
a long signal without that certain
condition it doesn't matter you just
copy the signal
and then uh automate that signal and let
me show you the process because
these indicators usually
work with a tick replay okay
click replay you go to data series
and
there is an option here
that if you turn that option on
that means that each time you refresh a
chart
each bar is calculated tick by tick
tick by tick for each bar that you have
on the chart this is really useful for
historical analysis because
take a look at this i don't have the
replay enabled so if i reload ninja
script everything is gone i don't have
more signals after the refresh only the
exponential moving average because this
is a standard indicator
but
this don't means that i am not going to
uh
example
you don't need to have thick replay
enable in your chart to trade live
if you are only interested in watching
the historical signals then yes
but let me show you a trick
um
here we are on playback okay
on playback
you can
select the option
playback the current day
and then if you click on go to
to the same time and date that we are
now so don't change nothing here
when you click on
ok it replace the whole day tick by tick
that means
that everything all the bars on the
current day not on all the chart are
calculated equating so the indicator
works and show the the signals okay
now uh
if you
let me let me also
explain the the
the two
main
features of markets in my opinion
um
i i
i at least
for me i have two problems one is the
distraction
and the second is a but that was an old
problem not currently but the fear
because um
maybe
from this signal
533 to this one
eight and we have three hours maybe i am
here
and i see that the market is not doing
nothing
so
just i leave my desk for five minutes to
do something and when i am back i see
this
perfect short with a perfect target and
i was distracted
so it is late now i cannot enter short
now because maybe the market is going in
the other direction so the instruction
is one of the
best
features uh that we can solve the the
best pro the
the worst problem that we can solve with
an automation tool where for example if
we are here
the market is going down and i am
waiting for my following short
and we are here and i need to go to the
bathroom for example i can enable the
following short
instead of automatic automatic means
that
you want to execute everything no i
don't want to execute everything i only
want to go short on the following signal
so i set
semi-automatic okay
then
i go to the
whatever
to get a cup of coffee
and
when the signal is detected by market it
is executed
with this atm
and that we have defined on chart trader
and when i am back to my desktop
because the signal was executed this
button is off because i am on
semi-automatic semi-automatic means that
if markers triggers an order
then the button is reset it is not going
to take anything else and even more
i am using this
atm
with
targets and stops that i defined
previously but i am in full control over
the targets over the stops and over the
positions
that means if i am short here
i can move the target
to the upside to the downside same for
the stop i can increase the position i
can close the position if i
i want to get out so i am in full
control this is not a strategy
where i can only sit and watch no i have
full control of
everything so this is
uh
really important for me because
maybe we have signals
with
hours of distance between one of them
and when the signal happens it happens
fast and we usually get a real
quick target so we cannot be distracted
so this is like
trading manually
but
automating the entry okay
the other problem
the other problem is i have time to
enter my tray
okay
i am
here
and the signal is painting
so
maybe i
if i am watching this live
and i am not automating the entry
maybe
this signal is painted while the bar is
moving
so maybe i can wait
see what happens
place a cell stop something like that
but anyway
there is a problem
that
happens when we
start to see
okay maybe this
signal is not
the same that all the other signals
maybe maybe this is a signal but maybe
this is an error so you start to er
to boycott your your plan because you
look to the upside this is a possible
double top
how can i go short if i have a double
or you are in a chat room and you
start paying attention to what people is
talking here
my suggestion okay
whatever you do when you test
when you back test your signals try to
repeat the same process when you are
trading live because when you back test
your setup
you never pay attention to what other
people are talking because maybe
there is someone that is going long here
and he if he is using a big a big stop
maybe he he he can get a target from
that
but anyway
the plan the trading plan from other
traders is not your trading plan so if
you
spend time
in back testing your setup
follow your setup okay
i i accept that you can add
more um condition for example i don't
know the the blue line is going down
i don't have
too many profit potential because this
is going to be
a resistance
anyway the signal is here
the problem is if you if you spend too
much time to decide maybe it is late
because the signals
are a
where you need to enter you you cannot
wait for a few words to see what happens
because when the target is touched there
is no more signal okay
so
it makes nonsense to enter here for
example because you may be a winner
here is a winner or not
so
with the automation of the entry you can
solve those two problems
now you can say okay
i i want to add to my setup i want to
add something like for example i am
watching this
historically and i see okay the short
signals are really nice when the blue
line is sloping
uh which is the worst signal this one
alone and the the blue line is sloping
down okay i i this is just an example
please don't ask me which is this line
this this is just an exponential moving
average this is an example this is a
slow moving average
but
this applies to any rule
so
yes you can add a lot of options for
example a filter we have the option to
filter signals
the filter means
that
markers detect the signals
check your conditions for example my
condition can be that the blue line must
be sloping up to enter long or sloping
up sorry sloping up to enter long
sloping down to enter show
short and you can also define
how how much
is that slope okay and now now we are
going to view an example but first of
all
let's try to automate this from the
beginning
so you can watch the recording several
times
as i mentioned
if i refresh this
i don't get more signals okay
but this is not so
difficult to solve because you have two
options or you enable
the tick replay
the tick replay has a problem that it
calculates take by take
all the bars all the parts of all the
days in your chart if you have a chart
with several days then it is going to
take
some time or just do a playback
with the option
playback current day
go to i don't know now
okay
so you get a
playback take back pick for today only
so you get the signals painted
now the question is okay how can i
automate those things the
we need
to copy the plots for the shorts and we
need to copy the plots for the longs
okay
so
when when
playback is doing this we cannot
interrupt
this is one of the problems there's no
stop because it is not doing a playback
it is
going to the starting point of the
playback so we can only sit and watch
i suggest selecting
a time
not at the end of the day
okay
so
let's remove everything
we need two copies
let me show you
uh okay
um
if i click on apply everything is gone
no problem
i i want to copy the plots from this
indicator
one for the lungs another for the shops
something
important this indicator
the indicator that i want to automate
works on each tick so
i need to copy
at each peak so marker stopping
at each tick
and
i i
choose a name for the signal
go long for example
and on input series i select which
indicator and which plot
the indicator is the flow shift okay so
indicators
flow shift
of course i need to set the same
parameters
that the indicator i have on the chart
because if not i am showing the signals
of one indicator on the chart and then i
and i i am automating the signals of the
same indicator but with different
parameters so that is not going to be
the same
on the plot i select which one they buy
okay
and
usually i choose
to select
a big
and because the copy
also
shows a dot or whatever
[Music]
something like that
i don't i cannot see nothing that's the
problem so
let's go again
i want to check if i am doing the copy
correct there was only one long at the
end
it should have
a dot from the copy
if i
did everything correct
yes
here we have the triangle and the dot
the dot is from the copy
usually
i
select that signal
right click
copy
and then
right click
no
select
anywhere
right click and paste just to avoid to
type all the input parameters of the
indicator that i copied so now i have
two
indicators
with the same
name
and it is already in use i cannot use
two copies with the same name so this is
something that we are going to fix now
but why i didn't copy and paste because
usually these indicators has a lot of
parameters and i don't want to
have an error or a typo
so on the second one
instead of how long go
short okay
and on the input series i have the
indicator already set with all the same
parameters i only need to change the
plot cell
it is
placing a dot
in color blue let's make it a dot in
color red
okay
[Music]
okay markers is using a link id
of one
these are default parameters
okay so everything is set
on markers
i said that i want to trade
past signals
and the name of the fast signals
those fast signals are coming from
the copies
the copy of go long
and the copy of row short
and i want to use those not as variables
i want to use them as a fast signal
okay
and okay
if i click on ok
and then i refresh all the chart i get
what we have previously
we can
try to automate everything in automatic
mode long and short
go to
just to check if everything is working
it is using when we do a go-to
ninja is using the maximum speed of the
playback
not 500 the maximum speed and we cannot
stop this because it again it is
going to
the
date and time that we selected
now we have a loser the loan
in any way if you pay a if you if we pay
attention to this loan
if we use an enough
look at that at the stop we enter we
enter long here and we are stopped out
but maybe if we use a bigger stop
when we get a short
the trade is reversed so
the this long
will be closed at this entry for the
short those are different ways to to
trade this now let's say i want to
filter those signals
taking into account this line there are
a lot of ways to do filtering or adding
logic to
to a signal
let me show you the simplest way the
simplest way is i want to calculate the
slope of this
the simplest way is to use markers slope
indicator
markers slope
and by default the name
of the
the slope is my slope we can do
whatever we can use any any number
i don't want to paint signal because my
slope is also
it can also paint signals but i i don't
want to paint any signals according to
the slope of this blue line because for
example i can paint
a short signal here or
a long signal here
i don't want to do this i only want to
store
the slope of the blue line into this
variable okay
and
where i place the blue line
inside input series
what is input series here
so here i need to place an exponential
moving average with the video
what is the
here
a pure of 100 okay
so
here
indicators
ema
okay
and i can paint the histogram
we can use this that color
[Music]
the
markers slope and exponential moving
average
don't need a thick replay so
after a refresh we can see the signals
something that i can do now
is using this as a filter
okay i only want to take short when this
is negative or longs when this is
positive how can i do that okay the we
we saw
that the name
of the slope
is my slope
so on markers
we can enable the filter enable filters
and
by default it is already set my slope is
greater than zero for loans
and for shorts my slope is less than
zero okay
okay
and now
if we
do a playback again
let's see we can see here
the result of the
filter
currently
longs are disabled and shorts are
enabled because the blue line is going
down
this short was not executed
and this is because the blue line is
sloping up
the long was not executed that's correct
and now the short is executed
and this is what we wanted the only
problem is i i would prefer to execute
that short tool but this is just an
example how how to add a filter to
signals that we have already configured
we can add more logic maybe this is a
filter but we can have a logic for
example i want
to
enter short only if the current bar is
read the previous word was red or the
current low of the bar is
lower than the previous low
or whatever you can imagine everything
is possible
you can showing signals several signals
and you can say okay i want to enter
short if
n bars ago i had another signal or yes
we have a lot of
configurations
and
this is uh for entry for exits the same
because we have the same that we saw for
entries can also be set for exits
maybe
i want
i don't know crossover
to
close a short or whatever
usually we use a signal to enter to
enter the market and another faster
signal to
exit the market
the same applies because if you go to
markers
we can we have a fast signal to enter
long and if a signal do enter short
but we can also enable exits
and we have
a fast signal to close my long and
another fast signal to close my short
okay so we have
multiple options if i enable this
i also
have the
option
to enable or disable this the same for
the filter because currently i am
filtering
i am filtering with the slope of the
blue line
but if
for some reason
i want to enter short here and i can see
that the lunar is going up so my filter
should be
the filter is short disabled but if for
some reason i want to enter short and
the following signal i can turn off the
filter
the same for this for the exits if i am
holding a position
and i don't want to close that position
on the following exit signal i can turn
this off also
um i guess i am
i have covered most of the
questions
i i also have something important
because um
[Music]
because of the of this webinar i have a
a very
interesting
coupon for those who may be interested
i i don't want to mention which is the
code because
this video is going to be posted
and the the offer is valid for a few
days only so if you are interested we
have a 30 discount a very big discount
on markers
send me an email send me an email asking
for
asking for that okay
and mike all yours
hey pablo no that was uh that was
fantastic actually i learned something
new there um
[Music]
uh
tell you
for people that aren't familiar with uh
markers it's a very robust system and
the way i use it i just by watching this
video sometimes i think i'm not getting
as much as i
as as i should
out of it
um
but
you know and and like pablo said he has
a
uh discord right and
you know he
he shares a lot in there and even on his
websites you know he has you know
templates and and things like that so
it's it's a it's a great uh great
resource for
for everybody um
so again you know
it's a great deal and especially 30 off
so email pablo um his website is the
indicator store which i'm sure most of
you are familiar with
um and take them up on that on that deal
i'm gonna take the screen back uh pablo
uh let me just
figure this out something or can you do
it from your end
um i'm gonna try and do it for my end so
just stay with me here
okay
um
all right so
it should be on my screen let me just
make sure
okay yeah so
just to wrap it up i'm not going to keep
you guys on much longer you know
pablo talked about the flow shifts
indicator again that works on
tick replay and i i will have a special
deal for everybody you know if those of
you that don't have that uh if you're
interested in that
um i'll send out a link later
but um you know recently we released a
new indicator called flow edges that
doesn't use tick replay um it just reads
the normal
order flow without you having to use
tick replay now you know what pablo is
talking about on
marker slope
you know is
is quite useful because you know that
can help keep you in a trade longer
especially you know when you are
talking about managing a trade you know
if you're in a trade say you're you're
short or less
say you're short from up here right and
you see the slope keeps going down
rather than getting out at you know your
your predetermined
take profit if you see there's a lot of
selling going on in the slope is
you know heading down and it's quite
steep you know maybe you could hold it
on longer that's what i'm a big believer
in
in trading is you have to trade right
you you want to make decisions now you
know i i do understand the whole concept
of you know we want to automate as much
as possible but you know at the end of
the day you know if you ever studied
edges right and you found an edge you
often find that you know sometimes your
edge doesn't
last very long right because as soon as
you find an edge maybe the market
conditions change and you know the one
of the problem with
back testing there's nothing wrong with
back testing you should always back test
your your ideas and your strategies
is
forward testing you also need to test it
i mean
you know all the big trading firms you
know the hedge funds the banks they've
data mined everything you know every
moving average you know sometimes yeah i
see people come up oh you know i've
found the perfect combination well
welcome to the party it's probably been
tested more in depth than than you have
and the way the markets are now are
different than they were a year ago and
it's different than they were 10 years
ago so you know i see people saying well
you got to back test your strategy on 20
years worth of data well
20 years ago
you know s ps were trading you know
what eleven hundred you know we're four
times as higher nasdaq is trading you
know what six thousand um it's a vastly
different market than it was a long time
ago
so pablo talked about the markers the
force the copy and you know i did get a
bunch of questions this last week about
flow breaks and will it work on
markers yes it it does it takes
i just get my screen up here excuse me
um just give it a second here i use
markers plus with copy
for longs copy for shorts i'm not going
to get into the actual settings of this
i'm going to probably create a separate
video on it but
another question i get is you know since
the flow breaks works
without tick replay how can you use it
with
um a footprint chart okay because you
know again yeah
i'm a big believer in the footprint
because that's you know telling you
what's happening
in the
in the order flow with the buying and
selling that's going on and you know if
you are
trading
you know i think it's best to look at
what the volume is doing in the market
and you know with the footprint you can
see where the aggressive buyer is coming
in where the aggressive sellers are
coming in etc and if you have
the flow breaks on a
norm on its normal bar chart
right
obviously when you take a trade on your
bar chart it will show up on your
footprint chart okay and you can just
manage it from there
okay so you can see here i'm just
running on oh this is just on tick
replay this is from the other night
so you can manage the trade from here
okay you know whether you want to
you know cancel it or close it or you
know move your
take profit up or down or you know maybe
you want to
move your stop closer there i just i
just can't like basically
move the stop to
to get out of the trade but you can do
that right and so you can use
you know the footprint chart
to manage your trades even if you're
getting in on a different chart and to
be honest
if you are
trading with
markers
you know using the slope now again you
know
you could use whatever
you know
indicator you want with the slope in the
sense of you know if you're using moving
average you use v web weighted moving
average exponential moving average all
of that right you can do it and again
there's no
right or wrong thing you know i just in
this example i just threw up a simple um
14 hma which is like the default right
but
you know maybe you don't want to be
taking
longs when
you know the slope is negative or you
don't want to be taking shorts when the
slope is positive you know you can
filter that out and
you know anything that's going to give
you a slight edge over somebody else in
the market is at the end of the day
going to help you as a trader and
your goal is to make money you know i
know everybody loves to talk about
nasdaq and think it's the greatest
market but for a lot of traders they
can't deal with the volatility you know
that's why i say you know when you're
using automated trading
find the market that resonates with you
the most that you can get dialed in on a
chart and you know levels in terms of
take profit and stop losses again you
can always adjust them right but you
have to be comfortable enough in your
in the market that you're trading in
your risk
to be successful right because not
everybody can trade nasdaq and be
successful at it you know we we all like
to think that you know we're robots but
you know at the end of the day many of
us are not we are just we're humans okay
so
again you know having
markers is is a great tool for traders
right it's going to really help you
in my opinion in your trading right
because it's going to help you get into
the trades when you should be getting
into the trades it can help you keep
keep you out of trades
by
you know using the tools that pablo has
already programmed in there
so
you know so you can see here right some
of these trades
um you know the shorts the longs
here got stopped out but
again it's when you think of automated
trading as opposed to manual trading
point and click trading right
when you're point and click trading
you're going to be slower than
the then you really want to be
unfortunately
um you know but this is a perfect
example right say
you know i'm getting
short here 7 47
three quarters okay i'm looking for the
move down did my take profit is 7 45 and
a quarter right
and it's just sort of hanging around
here it's hanging around break even
it's you know it's taken already 15
minutes it's just not going anywhere
i've seen the string of positive delta
fine i could just
close the trade out
i take
take my half a tick my two tick loss or
whatever it was there um there's just so
much you can do with it unfortunately
there's not enough time to cover
everything in these presentations again
pablo's got that great discord group
and he's got a great discount for
markers
if you're
interested in order
order flows trader software you go to my
website these are the links that i have
there and um you know i'll put the links
in the chat and again you know papa was
showing you flow shifts i i
i completely dropped the ball on that i
i i will send out a link for you guys to
save some money on flow shifts because
that is a one of our more premium
indicators that cost a bit more but i
would give you guys a special um savings
on that as well
as well as um the flow breaks indicator
so that you can get started and you know
incorporate parts of order flow into
your trading you know because as a
trader you want to have different
methods of trading now it's come up on
five o'clock so we've been on for an
hour um there are some questions here
uh again
um you know one of the questions how
much does markers cost just check the
website um i'll put the web
sites
in i'll put i'll show you pablo's
website here real quick um
the
whoops i can't type here indicator store
store.com so
here this is
excuse me um
here see i mean you can see there's many
different ways to use markers um
oh if you click on it so it's 9 45 so
you're saving 30 you're saving about 300
uh you know it's it's well worth uh it's
well worth it
you know especially at that deal
so
it's very good it's a great tool
and tiger king yes um
say
yes um this will be recorded and
it's
i'll just wrap it up here because
there's some questions that aren't
necessarily um
can be covered in this in this
presentation but
if
you use ninjatrader right and
ninjatrader just bought trade of eight
and so you know it's going to be
in my opinion i think now that
ninjatrader is getting bigger i like to
think that they're going to be doing you
know
bigger expansions into hopefully into
other markets especially things like
crypto and i i do think that
you know eventually though there will be
a bridge to a crypto exchange you know
keep my fingers crossed
um because crypto follows order flow
quite beautifully
and
you know there's more markets than just
trading e-minis and and nasdaq and mnq
so
you know it's good to get started with
ninjatrader get started with the order
flow get started with markers you know
because i've been using markers for
several years now probably about three
years
and
you know pablo keeps coming out with
some upgrades upgrades and making it
better i mean he's had it out since
ninjatrader 7 was
you know the software everyone was using
now we're on ninjatrader eight and it
keeps on getting better and and better
so
again this is pablo's website the
indicator market dot com
um so you know i so just get started on
that you know any questions specifically
um send pablo an email and you know if
you go on his website it's here if you
scroll down he's got his email on there
right here
pablo at the indicator store he's got a
little chat bot here's his email um it
is discord group okay you know and again
it's a great place where you know you
could share because you don't have to
just use it with my indicators it will
work with any other indicators that you
already have
okay so
thank you everybody thank you pablo for
coming out today um you know and again
you know
i do understand you know for some people
it's you know pablo's not in the united
states he's in south america so it's
it's quite late there and
he really tries to go that extra effort
with his software and everything for
everybody so i i honestly i don't get
any money from pablo when we do these
webinars together you know a lot of
people they do joint venture webinars
and they say oh give me a percentage i
don't ask that because i just think it's
a great tool for traders right and i
want you to be familiar with it
and get used to it right i mean i i
have markers but i paid pablo for it
right years ago i don't i don't ask him
for a free copy or anything just because
that's you know i believe in it and
it's just a great piece of software for
everybody so
anyway
can
i'll just end it there
so
i'm gonna there's some emails met
specifically for me um
philip
i'll get to your email i
i appreciate your comments but um
i'll get to it so
dennis
you know good tools
unfortunately cost money i honestly i
don't think that um
you know with with pablo's discount i
think it's a great uh great savings you
know that's the time to buy it is
right now um philip i will get your
email in
as soon as this is done
milby
uh
take a look there mill i'll make a note
for you movie
i'll send you out the latest version of
that
turns
and again you know people are gonna put
together you know a a video myself on
markers with couple of different
indicators because one of the questions
i do get quite often is
how to set it up with you know flow
shifts or turns or you know any of my
indicators and it's really simple you
know it really just takes a
i mean for me it's simple because i'm
used to it but it really only takes
not even a minute to set everything up
so
i'll end it there